merci tout le monde merci mais recevoir
chez vous en fait je suis vraiment adoré
d'être si mon père a été enseignant à
hec mon père qui est décédé l'année
dernière fait pour moi c'est particulier
de vous entretenir sur cette tribune
mon nom est david fortin une rose sur je
suis noro cologne et puis tout au long
de ma carrière je me suis intéressé aux
tumeurs cérébrales c'est ce dont je vais
vous entretenir je vais vous sortir de
votre zone de confort en passant je suis
vraiment nuls en économie j'ai aucun
conflit d'intérêts c'est à dire qu'ils
ont absolument aucun intérêt
pharmaceutique ou commerciaux dans la
présentation que j'ai pu faire
ok donc mon plat de présentation sera
comme suit
j'en parlais d'un cancer qui s'attaque
au cerveau je dois quand même vous
expliquer un petit peu grossièrement ce
qu'ils savent on en une minute
qu'est ce que le cerveau qu'est ce que
le cancer cérébral par la suite on va
s'intéresser aux obstacles principaux
dans le traitement du cancer cérébral
pour finalement terminer par ce qu'on
vous propose
je commence souvent ce type de
présentation en citant sur youtube est
ce que vous savez qui est surtout
surtout a écrit le plus vieux traités
d'art militaire de l'histoire de
l'humanité il ya 2400 ans menace une
source qui disait lorsque l'on part à la
guerre si on va avoir des chances de
gagner on doit d'abord se connaître soi
même puis évidemment bien connaître
notre ennemi donc c'est ce qu'on va
faire dans les prochaines minutes
ensemble on va commencer par définir
notre champ de bataille qui est le
cerveau pour bien comprendre les limites
imposées par ce champ de bataille par la
suite on va parler du cancer cérébral et
des principaux écueils que cette maladie
là nous avait pas et je devrais vous
entretenir du traitement actuel du
cancer cérébral pour comprendre ses
principales faiblesses
donc qu'est ce que le cerveau en une
minute qu'est ce que le cerveau le
savent aussi l'objet le plus complexe
connu dans l'univers entier le cerveau
réduit à sa plus simple à sa plus simple
expression pardon c'est une collection
de neurones donc le cerveau c'est 100
milliards de neurones 40 milliards de
ces neurones ne se retrouve au niveau du
cortex qui est une feuille de trois
mètres carrés de 3 mm des peines à
l'intérieur du cerveau ce qu'on va
retrouver essentiellement ce sont des
connexions de ces neurones et si chaque
neurone peut faire jusqu'à dix mille
connexions
c'est à dire que dans votre cerveau il
ya pour 40 x 10 à la 14 connexion en
terme d'ordre de grandeur que
vous savez ces 40 suivi de 14,0 en fait
eu autant de connexions cérébrales dans
votre cerveau qui auraient des toiles
dans notre galaxie donc un cerveau vue
de face ça ressemble à ça une résonance
magnétique chez un sujet normal
et là vous voyez apparaître en bleu ce
qui le cortex tout ce que vous voyez à
l'intérieur de cette zone bleue tu es là
c'est en fait les connexions des
neurones ce qu'on appelle des axones et
parsemés çà et là à l'intérieur de ces
connexions là il ya différents noyaux
profond dont le rôle est vraiment de
raffiner l'information je reçois
d'information sensitive motrices
émotives ou d'informations mais monique
la mémoire donc c'est un peu seul
cerveau donc comme je le disais il y
aurait autant de neurones et de
connexions neuronales dans un cerveau
humain que red des toiles dans la voie
lactée
vous voyez sur l'image de droite un
réseau neuronal locale et vous voyez
apparaître la voie lactée une similarité
ma foi dérangeant donc maintenant le
cancer cérébral
c'est pas le cancer cérébral il ya
plusieurs sous types de cancer cérébral
dont je vais vous en parlait de deux
aujourd'hui mais je vais passer
l'essentiel du propos à vous entretenir
sur le gliome glion vient d'un terme y
glisse qui veut dire coll si vous avez
tout le monde 100 milliards de neurones
dans votre cerveau dites vous que vous
avez 10 à 50 fois plus de cellules
gliales et c'est malheureusement c'est
celle là qui vont donner émergence au
cancer c'est remo lorsque ces cancers là
vont émerger
ils vont produire essentiellement trois
problèmes majeurs
le premier c'est l'hétérogénéité qu'est
ce qu'on veut dire par là bas c'est que
un patient qui va développer une tumeur
cérébrale va être unique
il ya pas une semence cérébrale qui est
identique ni en termes de taille de
localisation non plus qu'en terme de
de caractérisation biologique ça veut
dire que quand on essaye de traiter un
série de patients avec un cancer
cérébral
malheureusement un traitement unique
frappera pas la faire la deuxième
problème c'est le fait que les cellules
de séquences à la sont extrêmement
migratoires en fait ce sont les cellules
cancéreuses de tous les types de cancers
confondus qui ont la plus grande
capacité de migrer jusqu'à 1 cm par jour
et le troisième problème mais c'est un
problème qu'on appelle la barrière
hémato encéphalique
je vais vous entretenir un peu plus
longuement sur ce problème l'homme et ce
essentiellement de barrières entre les
vaisseaux sanguins du cerveau et le
tissu cérébral donc la premier problème
l'hétérogénéité qu'est ce que ça
implique bas un peu comme je vous disais
si vous prenez 10 patients avec des
tumeurs cérébrales vous allez avoir 10
caractéristiques différents lots 6 10
répondre de dix réponses différentes au
traitement qu'on va donner la deuxième
problème qui sera celui de
l'infiltration tumorales a des
implications c'est majeur
lorsqu'on regarde une résonance
magnétique on va voir le nodule
tumorales principal mais ce n'est que la
pointe de l'iceberg
il ya de nombreuses cellules qui vont
infiltrer à distance est souvent regardé
ici ça c'est une image qui fait de
laboratoire ou dans mon labo on a inséré
un échantillon du moral dans un gel qui
simule la matrice cérébrale ben vous
voyez que satisfait elle a décidé
d'aller faire du camping se détacher du
nodule principale avant les à distance
elle va fonder une colonie secondaires
qu'on vend plus une micro mais tape
stars dans leur imaginaire ici sur
l'échantillon les milliers de cellules
en périphérie de la tumeur qui vont
lentement et filtrer la matrice
cellulaire et vous comprendrez d'entre
eux dieu que c'est une maladie qu'on ne
peut pas guérir simplement par une
chirurgie donc c'est une maladie non
curative chirurgicalement
malheureusement ce à quoi comme
implications cliniques réel chez un
patient
vous voyez encore une résonance
magnétique en coupe de face comme
coronale avec le nodule du moral qui est
là et à la progression
ma foi ça peut avoir l'air de ça donc on
a vraiment impatients qui
malheureusement une maladie qui d'emblée
s'est répandu à l'autre hémisphère donc
lorsqu'on regarde une résonance
magnétique vous voyez comme moi la
tumeur vous voyez les contours de la
tumeur moi je peux vous dire je vais
aller opérer ça je vais aller enlever ce
qui apparaît
bleu en ce moment mais malheureusement
avec ce qu'on vient de voir vous
comprenez tout le monde qu'on va enlever
la pointe de l'iceberg et que c'est cela
qui va causer une distorsion
j'ai manqué une image 7 sentiment là qui
va causer une distorsion va
malheureusement aussi envoyé des
cellules à distance qui vont infiltrer
les fip steve qu'on voit apparaître ici
et c'est à distance disparu de là c'est
à distance le long de ces fait bloc on
sera pas capable malheureusement d'aller
cueillir les cellules tumorales et c'est
celle là qui la plupart du temps vont
produire une récidive tumorale la
barrière hémato-encéphalique notre
troisième problème
saviez-vous tout le monde que vous avez
pour 650 km des vaisseaux sanguins dans
vos têtes
ça paraît invraisemblable mais vous avez
100 milliards de neurones et chacun de
vos neurones au où on leur capillaires
cérébraux
donc vous avez pour 650 km des vaisseaux
sanguins et ses vaisseaux sanguins et là
sont pas du tout constitué de la même
manière avec les vaisseaux sanguins
qu'on retrouve ailleurs dans votre cas
ils sont prime ils sont pourvus d'une
barrière d'une forme d'étanchéité qui
situé au niveau de la paroi du vaisseau
sanguin qui fait que les cellules sont
vraiment attachés serrées les unes aux
autres par des complexe de protéines et
que si on veut donner un médicament qui
va traverser au cerveau ces médicaments
love va devoir passer à travers ces
fameuses jonction série qui parsèment la
paroisse de dessins de 650 kilomètres
des vaisseaux sanguins que vous avez au
cerveau donc la barrière
hémato-encéphalique un organe à
proprement parler un système de
filtration est essentielle au bon
fonctionnement de votre cerveau
malheureusement très nocif lorsqu'on
essaye nous d'acheminer des médicaments
thérapeutiques au cerveau donc ce sont
les trois problèmes dans le traitement
du serbe du cancer du cerveau pardon
ménargues regardons plus à fond quel est
le traitement standard du cancer
cérébral
c'est le traitement qu'on appelle le
protocole judo donc on commence par une
chirurgie et par la suite on va donner
de la radiothérapie combinée à de la
chimiothérapie à notre passion si on
regarde les trois problématiques qu'on a
discuté
tadjau de vous mentionner qu'avec ce
traitement à l'eau
quand vous voyez les résultats sont
plutôt modestes
donc on au passé avons progressé
classiquement environ six points neuf
mois la conclusion du traitement pour
des cds malheureusement environ 14 mois
à la conclusion de ce traitement donc ce
traitement alors malheureusement du
point de vue conceptuel partagent les
trois faiblesses convient de discuter
c'est un traitement unique offert pour
une maladie hautement hétérogènes alors
que ça peut très bien fonctionner pour
un patient ça ne fonctionnera pas du
tout pour un autre patient ensuite
lorsqu'on donne la radiothérapie à un
patient mais on va se trouver à a donné
une radiothérapie focaliser et donc non
petites cellules qui sont partis en
colonie
on va on voit pas les traiter de manière
adéquate et finalement le médicament qui
est devenu le standard de traitement de
chimiothérapie dans le traitement des
tumeurs cérébrales lattes et modales un
médicament spécifiquement conçu pour
traverser la barrière hémato
encéphalique bassin médicaments allonnes
le fait ne latraverse qu'à 20% sa 10e
qu'à vous donner un médicament vous
exposez votre patient à 100% toxicité
pour environ un cinquième de
l'efficacité donc ça c'est le problème
ce traitement actuel et sur le
traitement qui est utilisé en première
ligne partout dans le monde
alors quand on l'a fait quand on a fondé
le nom quand on quand on a fondé le
laboratoire de neuro oncologie à
sherbrooke
on s'est donné pour mission de
s'attaquer à ces trois problèmes
la premier auquel on s'est attaqué c'est
de franchir la barrière
hémato-encéphalique et on est maintenant
rendu à la clinique avec son on a
beaucoup de chemin de fait je vais vous
rappeler de manière plus détaillée là
dessus
ensuite ça s'est intéressée à considérer
l'hétérogénéité d'hétérogénéité du moral
vous allez voir on est rentré avec ça et
finalement le dernier problème auquel on
s'intéresse basse et la migration des
cellules gliales et on essaye
d'apprendre une solution unifiée qui va
frapper ces trois problématiques là
notre laboratoire a fait s'est fait un
nom je vous dirai à l'échelle du pays
puis par la suite à l'échelle
internationale d'abord et avant tout sur
nenon manipulation de
perméable isation de la barrière hémato
encéphalique c'est un peu comme ça qu'on
s'est fait un nom la première chose
qu'on a fait quand on a fondé
laboratoire c'est de se doter d'un
modèle de tumeurs animal qui était
reproductibles et utile il ya de
nombreuses investigateurs qui
travaillent avec des modèles qui sont
trop souvent factices qui vont produire
des résultats qui seront des faux
positifs ou des faux négatifs
alors on a travaillé fort pendant
plusieurs années a standardisé ce modèle
là qu'on appelle le modèle f 98 fait
chier c'est un modèle de tumeur
cérébrale chez l'animal vous voyez ici
qu'ont fait passer des résonances
magnétiques à nos animaux vous voyez
bien les tumeurs qui vont graduellement
poussé trois jours après implantation
jusqu'à 17 jours après implantation
on est capable de faire partie des
résonances magnétiques à nos animaux on
est capable d'en donner les traitements
de chimiothérapie
on est capable d'en donner des
traitements de radiothérapie et ses
armées de ce modèle là qu'on s'est
attaqué à la barrière
hémato-encéphalique alors la barrière
hémato-encéphalique puisqu'on a décidé
d'utiliser comme technique
c'est une technique qui implique les
fusions à l'intérieur des artères du
cerveau d'une solution hyper osmolaires
nous sommes une solution qui est très
concentré et qui aura pour effet de
virtuellement ouvrir moduler les
jonctions serré entre les cellules et
permettent le passage de molécules
thérapeutiques par la suite satisfait
leur est temporaire on le dit tantôt la
barrière hémato-encéphalique c'est un
film nécessaire au fonctionnement de
votre cerveau donc sa défaite en paroles
qui dure environ 15 minutes 15 minutes
pendant lesquelles on donne les
chimiothérapies directement au niveau
des artères cérébrales donc une
technique combine la chimiothérapie
intra-artérielle à l'ouverture de la
barrière hémato encéphalique
alors après avoir déployé cette
technique là on l'a utilisé évidemment
dans notre modèle animal sunday à pau un
peu chargé mais assez simple à
comprendre vous avez la coupe encore une
fois des phases de notre petit animal
avec son implantation tumorales ici et
vous voyez trois ans la zone bleue qui
définit la zone tumorale la zone rouge
qui définit la zone peritz moral autour
de la tumeur et la zone verte qui
définit l'hémisphère controlatéral une
sphère de l'autre côté vous voyez là
graphique qui est ici
les petits - des petits plus les plus
lorsqu'on utilise notre technique de
permis réalisation de la barrière
hémato-encéphalique et tout ça pour vous
montrer que avec cette technique lors
autant au niveau de la tumeur que autour
de la zone
perry tumorales mais même dans
l'hémisphère contre latéral on est
capable d'augmenter la livraison
d'engins thérapeutique voyant près la
même chose ici ou aveugles la
manipulation de la barrière hémato
encéphalique
et après d'ailleurs une augmentation
assez importante dans l'étendue du
signal donc cette technique modèle
animal fonctionnait très bien
on a publié de nombreux tapis la tuer
par la suite on est passé chez l'être
humain
on a commencé à offrir ces traitements
la seul à être humain et on a publié
plusieurs papiers je vous dirais sur
cette technique permet habitations de la
barrière hémato encéphalique
est ce que ça marche ça marche très bien
vous voyez la tomographie axiale le scam
qui est derrière moi vous savez tout le
monde que notre cerveau et est pourvu de
deux hémisphères ont fait l'ouverture de
la barrière seulement dans un des deux
hémisphères à ce patient l'on
administrait un contraste est revenu au
préalable à l'ouverture de la barrière
et vous voyez que tout l'hémisphère qui
situés à gauche sur l'écran est
complètement délavé par le produit de
contraste et 15 minutes après
l'ouverture de la variable vous voyez
que je produis contre ans commencent à
se délier invite donc ça marche très
très bien vous pouvez imaginer qu'un
médicament qu'on va donner par les
artères du patient va avoir le même type
de distribution que le produit de
contraste que vous voyez ici
est-ce que c'est sécuritaire maintenant
question évidemment très important parce
que c'est pas une procédure que de
mettre un cathéter dans les artères du
patient et faire ce type d'approché
leurs sous anesthésie générale
la réponse est oui c'est extrêmement
sécuritaire comme vous voyez sur les
données ici qu'on a présenté il ya deux
ans congrès dans l'oncologie
on a traité plus de 700 patients de plus
de 3500 procédure vous voyez les trois
types de maladies qu'on a traitées donc
les gliomes les fameux gliome donc je
vous entretenais mais aussi des
métastases cérébrales et d'éléphants les
bombes sont un autre forme de cancer
primaire puis je vais je vais vous
montrer des données là dessus
très bientôt donc on a traité ces trois
types de maladies là et globalement on a
un taux de complications qui est de
l'ordre de 0,75 pour ça donc je pense
qu'on peut dire que c'est relativement
sécuritaire pour une procédure aussi
agressive on a fait la première
procédure chez un jeune patient en 2001
donc madame marois je le droit de les
nommer parce que c'est une personne qui
a été pas mal médiatisé qui est encore
toujours vivant 18 ans après son
traitement
elle avait été traité pour un lymphome
du système nerveux central la réforme du
système nerveux central c'est une
maladie pendant l'agressive en fait très
agressive
c'est une maladie assez rare aussi il ya
sept corps par tranches 2 millions
d'habitants environ 50 cas par année au
québec donc une maladie assez rare sur
laquelle on n'a pas beaucoup de données
mais globalement ce qu'on peut dire
c'est globalement non traités les
patients vont survivre trois mois traité
avec l'ancien traitement un traitement
qu'on a eu en vogue jusqu'au début des
années 90 juste la radiothérapie des
patients survivent et environ 1
malheureusement le problème avec la
radiothérapie c'est que pour cette
maladie le spécifiquement cette modalité
de traitement qui est relativement
toxiques
et lorsqu'on utilise la radiothérapie la
chimiothérapie les meilleurs chiffres
qu'on est capable d'avoir ses environs
36 mois donc autour de 3 ans de
traitement
c'est ce qu'on peut offrir de mieux avec
le avec ce type d'approché avec le
traitement d'ouverture de la barrière
hémato-encéphalique on une médiane de
survie qui frise la 4e ça utiliser la
radiothérapie
on a le cinquième de nos patients qui
sont toujours vivants et l'autre chose
qu'on remarque qui est fascinant c'est
que contrairement à la plupart des
données qu'on retrouve dans la
littérature même nos patients très âgés
survivre très bien on voit pas de
différence dans la réponse de traitement
en fonction de l'âge et sont les
premiers à démontrer
juste pour vous montrer un exemple de
réponse le les formes quand ça répond ça
répond très bien et très vite ça c'est
après seulement deux mois de traitement
qu'en est il des fameux glion maintenant
balle et guillaume c'est toute une
classe de maladie mais je vous parle
juste du gliome de grade 4 le plus
agressif le glioblastome la survie
médiane ce bioplastique comme jeu
ce n'est de 14 mois avec le traitement
standard avec le traitement d'ouverture
de barrières et de chimiothérapie est
artérielle qu'on fait nous ont fait
passer ça à 25 mois on dit on double
presque la survie c'est intéressant
c'est évidemment nettement insuffisant
puis l'autre chose qui est remarquable
c'est que si on dit qu environ 50% de
nos patients vont répondre réponse
complète réponses partielles maladie
stable et progression ici on voit qu'il
ya quand même 23 points 5 % pratiquement
la cas de la cua 23 points 5 % de nos
patients qui ne répondent pas du tout
qui vont d'emblée progresser à mesure
qu'on a développé la chimiothérapie être
artérielle et l'ouverture des barrières
on a développé plusieurs médicaments
contre va donner une manière sécuritaire
par voie intra artérielle
ne vous attardez pas au nom des
médicaments
sachez juste qu'il ya cinq agents de
chimiothérapie pour les sens qu'on peut
donner par cette approche là on est
toujours à la recherche d' améliorer
cette liste elle est ce qu'on a remarqué
c'est que comme je vous mentionnais tout
à l'heure dans un contexte
d'hétérogénéité tumorales chaque passe
un différend sur le patient ne répond
pas au carboplatine il peut très bien
répondre à cette honte agent ici qu'on
appelle la méthode rexel nous avons donc
remarquer que le profil de réponse des
patients étaient très variables et
unique à chaque patient d'où la
prochaine idée que nous avons eues pour
traiter le deuxième problème que
l'hétérogénéité tumorales alors plutôt
qu'offrir le même traitement tous les
patients
ce qu'on entend ce qu'on entend faire et
c'est cette étude là elle est écrite
elle est acceptée et elle vient tout
juste de débuter ce qu'on entend faire
c'est d'abord réopéré les patients pour
procéder à une réfection la tumeur
prendre un échantillon de la tumeur et
l'amener au laboratoire voyez si laurent
livier qui m'ont étudiants aux péages
les qui amène les échantillons au
laboratoire et la soumettre cet
échantillon là à des tests ex vivo à
l'extérieur du patient des tests de
chimio sensibilité donc on prépare
l'échantillon on les expose aux
différents agents chimio et on génère
des courbes comme les courbes que vous
voit
ici vous avez deux courts décembre 2010
8 février 2019 dans deux échantillons
différents de passer en différents qui
montre des réponses très différent plus
lacombe est élevé vous avez le contrôle
ici plus les cellules tumorales sont
actives plus la courbe est basse plus la
joie de chimiothérapie et efficace donc
dans l'échantillon numéro un on voit que
le médicament appelé état possible est
extraordinairement efficace alors que
pour la personne numéro 2 ça serait
utile d'utiliser les tapas in les
cellules continue à pousser à vitesse
grand v
même lorsque exposé à cet âge elle le
carboplatine pour ce patient leur la
doxorubicine pour le premier passage
sera efficace le car blanc seing pour le
deuxième patient serait une alternative
donc on génère des scores de sensibilité
comme vous voyez ici sensible
intermédiaires et résistant puis on fait
batterie de tests de jeunes qui vont
aussi prédire une bonne réponse est basé
là dessus on va sélectionner notre
médicaments de chimiothérapie qu'on va
offrir aux patients donc voici la
solution au problème d'hétérogénéité
tumorales
finalement il nous reste un problème
celui de l'invasion des cellules gliales
ya de nombreux investigateurs qui ont
tenté d'empêcher la migration des
cellules gliales et ça n'a pas
fonctionné
et ça c'est vraiment l'idée de mon
assistant de laboratoire gabriel qui je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce que
générer cette idée leur est inondée
jenny se dit au lieu d'empêcher la
migration des cellules gliales utilisons
cette propriété là pour essayer
d'attirer les cellules gliales var où
vont les veut donc l'idée céderait opéré
les patients d'implanter un gel qui
contient des molécules qui ont la
capacité d'attirer les cellules gliales
sexuelle 10
ce sont ce qu'on appelle des chignons
attract et en utilisant ces molécules
hla les cellules gliales qui ont
infiltré le cerveau vont être landemer
rapatriés vers la cavité chirurgicale et
à l'intérieur de la cavité chirurgicale
dans notre gel il ya des substances à
libération lente de chimiothérapie mais
aussi des radio isotopes et on va
utiliser une technique de cheval de
troie pour tuer des cellules
al donc trois problèmes 3d différentes
qui seront déployés simultanément dans
le traitement des tumeurs cérébrales
juste pour vous mentionnez ce travail là
que je vais lui parler et seulement au
niveau de la recherche préclinique on
est en laboratoire avec ça on n'anticipe
pas débarquer en clinique à vers 3 ou 4
ans mon étudiant qui travaille là dessus
la danse des reer a gagné un prix cette
semaine pour ce travail et l'ont donc
vous voyez que ces tours et ça va mon
fiston qui est ici participent à ce
projet là les rentes à l'université
l'année prochaine j'espère qu'il va
continuer ce travail
ça serait intéressant donc je termine en
vous disant que c'est bien beau tout ça
c'est bien beau la science
les graphiques les scans la recherche
les papiers mais notre job ma job c'est
d'aider les gens puis pour aider les
joueurs font non seulement
j'améliore la durée de vie de faut que
j'améliore aussi leur qualité de vie
parce que ce que je fais moins d'abord
et avant tout c'est pas travailler avec
des des publications ni avec des escales
mais c'est correctement donc nathalie
puissance une danseuse de ballet qui a
fondé la fondation karanta c'est notre
laboratoire qui est décédé d'un gliome
pas le boisvenu qui le frère du sénateur
boisvenu est aussi décédé d'un
glioblastome mystère et un patient qui
rend ce moment et sous traitement actif
et pour l'instant il répond très très
bien donc je vous laisse là dessus ça me
faut président à prendre mes questions
la peau si vous en avez merci de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]